[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous je suis ma
boule à soumahoro je tiens à m'excuser
de ne pas pouvoir être avec vous ce soir
même si j'aurais vraiment bien aimé être
avec vous la vie a fait que cela n'est
pas possible mais je suis très heureuse
de participer même virtuellement cette
tenue du tedx à saint-ouen et je
remercie catherine et annie pour cette
belle invitation
ce soir pour la première édition de tedx
quai de saint-ouen il m'a été demandé de
produire un texte sur la thématique du
regard j'avoue que la question m'a
beaucoup intrigué mais j'ai décidé de
relever le défi et pour cela je vous
propose de cheminer avec moi tout en
mêlant du vécu personnel avec mes
domaines de recherche qui sont consacrés
à la diaspora noire africaine
la scène se passe dans un commissariat
de la banlieue sud parisienne je suis
prêt adolescente et je me rends dans ce
commissariat avec ma famille nombreuse
pour
aller récupérer et me demander ma
première carte d'identité française
c'est une première et c'est un peu le
graal pour ces familles d'immigrés dont
font partie mes parents qui sont
originaires de la côte d'ivoire et qui
sont arrivés en france dans les années
60 donc pour l'ensemble de ces immigrés
l'accession à la nationalité française
parfois pour eux mêmes ou parfois pour
leur enfant peut constituer un graal le
jour est donc important nous sommes dans
les années 1980 mon tour arrive je passe
devant l'officier de police qui me
demande les papiers requis qui ont bien
été remplie qui me mesure et qui remplit
à son tour la partie réservée à
l'administration au moment où je
récupérerai maca l'identité française je
m'apercevrai que mes cheveux ont été
décrites comme noir et que mes yeux ont
également été décrit comme noir le
problème est que mes cheveux sont on
peut en discuter assez noir mais en
vérité sont marron très foncée et
d'ailleurs quand ils sont longuement
exposées au soleil cela apparaît
beaucoup plus clairement quant à mes
yeux ils ne sont absolument pas noir mes
yeux sont marron ils sont marron et ils
sont même serti de bleu donc ce bleu
profond ce blu ce bleu couleur marine
qui entourent mes yeux a longtemps fait
la fierté de ma famille avant que l'on
s'aperçoive des années plus tard qu'ils
étaient en réalité la marque d'une
pathologie ophtalmologiques mes yeux
sont marron et sertie de bleus quand
j'ai été au commissariat préadolescente
on ne m'a aucunement posé des questions
ni sur la couleur de mes cheveux nice et
sur la couleur de mes yeux j'étais une
enfant noir j'étais une fille l'immigré
j'étais une africaine et en cela
automatiquement j'ai été catégorisés
j'ai été perçue j'ai été regardée comme
noir en toute logique en tant que être
noir mais d'une meyzieu devait également
être noir la vie est censé être si
simple j'ai patiemment attendu les dix
années séparant les missions de ma
première carte d'identité et son
expiration à un âge à laquelle un âge où
j'étais devenu adulte entre-temps jeunes
adultes et quand il a s'agit de
renouveler cette première carte
d'identité j'ai corrigé moi même ce
qu'on pourrait appeler ou considéré
comme une erreur administrative et j'ai
indiqué que mes yeux était marron
dix ans plus tard comme dix années
auparavant
on ne m'a rien demandé une noix avec les
yeux marrons ça passe également
à l'âge adulte j'ai je me suis j'ai
entamé des des études consacrées à la
diaspora noire africaine c'est à dire
les populations d'ascendance africaine
dispersés à travers le monde atlantique
dans le cadre de la traite négrière
transatlantique
et ses études m'ont permis de
m'expliquer un peu ma vie et mon
expérience donc le lien que je fais avec
cette anecdote qui pourrait paraître
tout bonnement anodine le lien que je
peux établir aujourd'hui me renvoie des
lectures qui sont celles de l'africaine
américaine toni morrison et de la
guadeloupéenne maryse condé française
donc je m'intéresse à ces deux auteurs
dans ce qu'elles ont pu écrire sur le
regard sur les yeux et sur la perception
du regard et de les yeux notamment à
travers deux romans qui m'ont qui m'ont
particulièrement touché et qui font écho
à cette anecdote par laquelle j'ai
débuté il s'agit du premier roman de
toni morrison qui s'appelle l'oeil le
plus bleu et qui a qui est paru en 1970
et en attendant la montée des eaux le
un des romans publiés par maryse condé
en 2010 dans chacun des romans il s'agit
de parler de personnages noirs qui ont
des yeux bleus dans le cas de toni
morrison et l'oeil le plus bleu il
s'agit de l'histoire de la petite
africaine américaine du nom de peco
l'abri de love qui prient chaque soir et
qui désirent ardemment acquérir des yeux
bleus selon p cola breedlove ses yeux
bleus qui peuvent être considérés comme
les atours de la blanche citée comme la
beauté blanche lui permettrait de sortir
du marasme de sa vie jalonnée d'un
inceste paternel d'ailleurs est aussi
exclu du regard bienveillant de sa
famille tant de sa famille que de la
société extérieure puisqu'on parle d'une
société étasunienne hyper racialisée et
qui considèrent que le noir est la
figure de la laideur le noir est
inférioriser peco l'abri de l'homme à la
fin du deuil le plus beau ne parviendra
pas et c'est évident à acquérir des yeux
bleus et sombrera dans la folie dans le
cas de maryse condé cette approche des
yeux bleus est un peu différente je
m'intéresse ici au personnage de tecla
minerve qui est la mère du personnage
principal de en attendant la montée des
yeux et qui elle est extraordinaire par
les yeux bleus qu'elle arbore et qui
sont associés une fois encore à un corps
noir donc l'association entre corps noir
et les yeux bleus est tout à fait
inattendue tout à fait mystérieuse et
rend le personnage de tecla minerve
attrayante attirante séduisante c'est à
dire que l a obtenu quelque chose de la
blanche cité cependant pour maryse condé
ses yeux bleus font tout d'abord écho à
la traversée transatlantique au passage
du milieu c'est à dire que les yeux
bleus dont a hérité
tecla minerve de la guadeloupe
partent en vérité d'une douleur d'une
souffrance et cette douleur et cette
souffrance nous renvoie à la souffrance
et à la douleur de l'arrachement du
continent africain c'est en effet la
gueule éloigné de tecla mineurs minerve
ou ans gars 1 qui lors de son
déplacement violent depuis les côtes
africaines vers le continent américain a
tellement pleuré sur le bateau négrier
que la couleur de ses yeux est passé de
brune à bleu et cette évolution de la
couleur des yeux a été transmise de
génération en génération assez minerve
qui sont maintenant originaire de la
guadeloupe donc on voit bien que pour
toni morrison le bleu des yeux qui est
associé à la halle a blanchi t et ce qui
va rendre complètement folle la petite
peco l'abri de l'homme mais c'est
l'objet de son désir alors que dans le
cas de maryse condé la personne noire
qui bénéficient des yeux bleus même si
socialement et esthétiquement elle est
très valorisé pour cette question en
vérité le fait de posséder ses yeux
bleus la place à la marge de sacre de sa
propre communauté et en cela cela ne
comprenons cela ne constitue aucun
bénéfice aux qu'elle voudrait se
raccrocher d'éclat minerve
en ce qui me concerne je suis moi même
une femme noire et mes yeux sont marron
cette couleur marron ne convient
parfaitement et je ne la changerait pour
aucune autre ce que j'ai appris depuis
longtemps
depuis cette première confrontation avec
un commissariat français qui devaient
m'octroyer ma première carte d'identité
c'est que il était important que je
puisse me regardez moi même et de
m'accrocher à ma réalité les personnes
qui ont décrété que mes yeux étaient
noirs ne m'ont pas regarder ne m'ont
rien demandé et n'ont perçu que mon
corps est dans cette logique de
perception de catégorisation strict de
mon corps il était logique que j'ai des
yeux noirs depuis cet épisode qui date
de ma pré adolescence j'ai décidé de
m'accrocher et de m'ancrer fermement
dans une réalité dans une vérité auquel
nous devrions tout et tous avoir le
droit afin de conclure cette
présentation je voudrais vous rappeler à
quel point il est important quand on
pense à la question du regard de pouvoir
s'en départir ce regard ou tel qu'il est
construit par l'histoire tel qu'il est
construit est telle qu'il a cours
aujourd'hui encore dans la société dans
laquelle nous vivons et dans toutes les
sociétés dans lesquelles nous pouvons
évoluer ce regard a parfois le pouvoir
d'en fermer de corse était de force et
de limiter et ce que je souhaite à
toutes et à tous c'est de pouvoir sortir
de se libérer de ce corset je vous
remercie de m'avoir écouté et de
l'attention que vous avez pu porter aux
propos que j'ai tenus ce soir je tiens
également à remercier toute l'équipe du
tedx quai de saint-ouen et j'espère avec
grand plaisir pouvoir vous rencontrer un
jour cette fois de manière physique en
présentiel comme on dit aujourd'hui et
non plus au virtuel bonne soirée à
toutes et à tous
[Musique]